Ciao ragazzi bentornati a una puntata
di Cucina Buttata, oggi stiamo per fare
uno dei prodotti più famosi e amati nel mondo
stiamo parlando della nutella. Un pochino
di settimane fa ho ricevuto su whatsapp
questo meme, da una parte vediamo la nutella
dall'altra vediamo tutti gli ingredienti
che la compongono divisi a strati
In realtà non è proprio questo il meme che ho ricevuto
perché quello che ho ricevuto io non
si può far vedere, ma mi sono subito
chiesto, se questi sono veramente gli
ingredienti presenti all'interno della
nutella, che cosa ci vuole a farla?
Perché avete riso? Non era una battuta - Il tuo ragionamento...(Gianmarco) - Non fa una piega
- Ma il risultato... (G)
- Il risultato si, può variare, comunque...
Partiamo... - comunque scusa, sei sicuro non si può far
vedere? (Enrico) - Tutte le pagine instagram lo fanno vedere, perché tu non puoi farlo? (G)
- Allora facciamolo vedere il meme.
Partiamo subito col procedimento
Per fare la nutella avremo bisogno di: olio
di palma, che non è presente all'interno
dei supermercati, quindi abbiamo trovato
un'alternativa che è un olio di semi di
girasole. Senti gli metti delle palme sopra e fingiamo che sia olio di palma?
Olio di palma, latte in polvere, che è introvabile e
quindi alla fine abbiamo trovato latte
crescita dai 2 ai 3 anni della mellin
Ho dei dubbi che questa cosa funzioni però
volevamo essere più fedeli alla ricetta
possibile. Cacao in polvere, mandorle tostate
- Ma che mandorle c'è scritto nocciole grosso
quanto una casa! (E)
- Bravo, sei attento. Nocciole tostate...e zucchero
zucchero. Posso dire che personalmente
sono veramente curioso di vedere se
questa roba funziona. Non so quanto sia
in realtà capito una roba
sensazionalistica, della serie "Guarda
quanto zucchero ti mangi!" - Mi sembra un po'
esagerato. E infine avremo bisogno di lui,
un barattolo misuratore della nutella
Ragazzi parliamoci chiaro, cioè con ogni
probabilità non faremo la nutella perché
stiamo seguendo un meme, manco la ricetta
originale ma ero curioso di vedere
quanto realistico fosse e siccome io non
sono stupido oltre al barattolino che
noi riempiremo ho anche una piccola
porzione di nutella reale per poterla
assaggiare e vedere quanto si avvicina o
quanto si allontana dal consiglio del
web. Partiamo! Allora teoricamente lo zucchero
prende un terzo a occhio ragazzi, anche
di più. Secondo me ci può stare
Nocciole tritate. No, devo triturarle?
- Nel meme come so? (E) - Tritate
Nocciole tritate che non vedo l'ora di tritare. Ohhh...grande!
Il potere della nutella "Ciak"
C'è un bello strato - Ci sta ci sta (E) - Cacao leggermente
di meno - Stai facendo un buon lavoro...sembri tipo quelli la che fanno le opere d'arte nei barattoli (E)
- Vero? Mi sento veramente in gamba. Sembra che io
non ho fatto altro nella vita. E adesso il
momento che preferisco, il latte per il
bebè da due a tre anni. Io però vorrei...
- Quello non c'entra niente con il latte in polvere (G)
- Io sono tornato indietro nel tempo - Ti ha ricordato qualcosa? Prova a tornare indietro anche te (G)
- Torna indietro nel tempo - Ma è buono! (E)
- Eh vabbè ci manca pure che faceva schifo che schifo - ...Che schifo! Sono tornato indietro
- Così li mischi così li mischi se fai questa roba (E)
- Ok. E infine olio
Quello che direi di fare
io adesso è vuotarlo qua dentro e frullare
Non ho idea di cosa aspettarmi,
cioè mi sembra assurdo capito?
Troppo liquida ragazzi. Ho bisogno di un aiuto dal web "Come fare la nutella" - Ma che c'hai sulla maglia Gu? (E)
- Oh una spilla, questa qui è la maglietta del
pride che ha fatto Ralph Lauren. Grazie Ralph
No regà, ho beccato Chef Stefano Barbato
Di quando è questo video? Del 2015. Siamo contenti di arrivare sempre qualche anno
dopo lite alle ricette. La cuoce a bagnomaria. Proviamo?
- Menomale che c'è Chef Stefano! (G)
-Menomale! Infatti ti aspettiamo ormai,
almeno qualcosa viene fuori. Non ha una
bella faccia - E' un po' bruttina eh (E) - Brutta? Mostruosa! Il calore risolve tante cose, umano e non
- E' probabile flop (E) - No non essere così duro - Chef Barbato avrà usato
altre dosi Gu (E) - Certo ma noi stiamo
seguendo quelle del meme
mica stiamo seguendo la sua ricetta - Eh ma quindi cioè che stai facendo? Non viene! (E)
- Ecco dimmi  il tuo parere infatti... Sai qul è
secondo me il segreto di Chef Barbato?
Che quando lui ha imparato era silenzioso
avrà rubato con gli occhi. Sii come Chef Barbato quando studiava - E' orrida ragazzi! Pare davvero pesto (G)
- Io vorrei vedere quando lo zucchero inizia a
sciogliersi allora cosa succede. E poi soprattutto il
processo di Maillard - ... - E' come se lì dentro avessi messo una piccola dose di nutella...
- Si è vero - ... Nel liquame (E) - (*suono di ambulanza*) - E' qui!
- No ragazzi (E) - E poi fa un odore
raccapricciante. Allora io posso proporre
una cosa? Lo versiamo all'interno di
questo coso qui e lo lasciamo riposare
- Forse te lo dico, una delle cose più orride che hai cucinato (G)
- Non è che sotto sotto...il latte? Ma ti pare che non lo puoi riscaldare per il tuo
bambino? - Ma qual è il motivo? (E) - Forse c'era un sacco d'aria in mezzo?
- Nonono (G) - E certo che lo devi mettere, è fondamentale quello
- Beh ragazzi un fallimento. Ma dobbiamo assaggiare veramente quella cosa? (E) - Ti giuro si. Farà cagare!
Pantaloni già sbottonati. In questo momento la sensazione è che abbiano invertito il processo della
catena alimentare - Cioè che se magna col c**o? (E)         - Che se magna col c**o
- Facciamo riposare questo liquame, la liquella
La riprendiamo fra tra un po',
capace anche la lasciamo riposare per sempre
Raga fermi tutti - Che c'è? (E) - E' inutile aspettare
- Noo (E) - No no (G)
- Questo è quello che succede quando si
ascolta la voce dei meme, la voce dei meme
dice solamente una cosa, me me me, una
voce egocentrica che non cerca la verità
O siamo noi che veramente non sappiamo unire nemmeno cinque ingredienti
- La salamoia di Roger rabbit - Vado io prima
Scusate venite ad assaggiarla un secondo
- Ti piaciuta? - Fa cacare al c***o! - Ma lo senti? - Quel retrogusto infinitesimale - ...Dai non tutto il cucchiaio
- Io sento solo zucchero ragazzi. Non è malvagia - No non è agghiacciante
Ma di che stiamo parlando ragazzi?! - Che  schifo!
- La cosa più fallimentare mai vista in questa cucina           - Mai vista, mai vista una cosa così fallimentare
Ragazzi questo naturalmente non è un
video che vi invita a riprovare a fare
questa ricetta - Noi siamo costretti per colpa tua
e delle tue idee ad assaggiare quello
- C'è da dire che non si può sempre criticare il capitano quando il mare è mosso
se poi te porta...con la sua nave lontano.
E' vero, andiamo a dormire sapendo di aver
fallito - ...per essere più forti (E) - ...domani, quando - ...troveremo il mare piatto (E) - e
- ...la nave (E)
- Punto
A parte gli scherzi ci dispiace veramente di avervi rubato minuti preziosi della vostra vita
Io sono in imbarazzo, sono dispiaciuto
Seguite a questo punto la ricetta di
Chef Barbato, che mettiamo nel link in
descrizione, non è la nutella ma comunque
una cosa che alla fine è mangiabile. Io come sempre
vi invito a iscrivervi a questo canale se vi abbiamo strappato una risata ma
soprattutto ad attivare la campanella
delle notifiche per non perdere i
prossimi video. Noi ci vediamo la
prossima domenica sempre ai 12 con una
nuova puntata di Cucina Buttata. Ciao
- Comunque io penso che tu ci debba delle scuse (E)
- Si, scusatemi ragazzi. Io pensavo che sarebbe stata tipo "Oh cavolo!" - E' stato invece proprio "Cavolo!" (E)
- "C***o!" . Tagliate tutto